today's topic i'm ugly okay and so we
need to just get right to it
here's the thing right i say i'm ugly
and then people freak out oh abba
are you fishing for comments no it's not
oh abba no do you just want us to say
nice things
here's the thing right you have to
understand i've built my identity on the
idea of believing i was ugly and to be
fair
early on in my life i really was there's
no way around it
you can't justify all the rejections
i've faced with any other solution
other than i'm ugly and i've accepted it
i've built my entire personality
around accepting the idea that i'm ugly
and i'm gonna overcome it
yeah speak yo so follow me so so maybe
over the last three four years you know
as i've bulked up a little bit as i've
gotten my hair right
okay i've fixed a lot of things right
maybe now you
the world sees me as potentially kind of
attractive some of you are going to be
in the comments like nah
are you still ugly it's okay but for me
that has always been my perception of
myself it doesn't bother me it isn't sad
in me
i've accepted it it's okay now when
someone comes to me
and they're like abba no no you don't
understand you're a beautiful man i'm
like
thanks and they know you understand like
you can say it a hundred times it's not
gonna change nothing no
okay cool that's not gonna change the
fact that i don't like compliments
either
i mean some compliments are nice you
know i understand what you're saying
but i on the ugly thing and i i totally
understand what you're saying about the
ugly thing like
i grew up an ugly kid and i was not yeah
it was not
i was ugly haitian uh black kid white
neighbor it was like everything all the
odds against me right yeah
and it's like i get it you build
you build on something else you you have
to build on something else you have to
sorry sorry sorry
sorry sorry sorry there was just like a
manifestation of newness that was coming
out and i was like let me live
live this moment my policies you were
talking
she's even mad can you stop i'm not even
back because i'm not the only have to
come out
yeah i just felt like that i'm so good
at making another invitation
this is just some okay don't let my
insecurities distract you
get it i had to self reflect and know
why i don't like compliments like that
it's really comes down to when i was a
kid
and i was growing up and people when
they made compliments it was really just
a joke
hey you're cute ah thank you psych
but flip side you've told me a story
where a girl approached you and you
didn't want to believe that she was
attracted so he's like yo what's your
problem
you got mad at her for approaching you
yeah cause she was part the thing is
that it's one of the girls that was in
my
in my class and she was friend with
another girl that was not in my class
but she was the one that gave her the
letter
but the thing that happened is that she
was they were part of the class she was
like the queen
of the clique that didn't want to mess
with me at all
and that was dogging me so the flip i
was like okay
okay listen you messed with me i left
you alone
now you coming why right like what what
is wrong with you i
left you and that's why i was pissed off
because i was like yo i left you alone
stop messing with me
why are you messing with me yeah yeah
one oftentimes obviously
at that age you know you hate on the
people you like yeah so that's pretty
common yeah and the second thing i would
tell you is like
women who grew up ugly and turned
beautiful later on are always the
juiciest
as far as the good looking girls from
the high school they look like dump
trucks right now
i mean some hey girls some no someone
look no
yeah it's always fun to see like someone
fall from glory you know yeah
yeah you're always just like damn you
was the one in high school
now you damn
god bless you i feel sorry for you and
oh yeah it's like yeah here's a weird
thing some people get mad when you're
not
like enthralled with their compliment or
they get a little bit upset you know why
is that
why because they do the compliment not
for you they do it for them
yeah part i would agree with that and
i'm just like why are you imposing your
reality or your vision of me on me if
you think i'm beautiful
you're right if i'm think i'm ugly i'm
also right
everything is subjective when it comes
to compliments both of those things can
co-exist
so if you want to drop a compliment to
someone just say it go ahead
be like this what i think of you and if
the person takes it some weird way
that's their choice
you have to say it because you want to
give it don't be all like
i'm allowed to view myself i want to
view myself and you're getting
frustrated and trying to impose your
view of me
it's a waste of time when someone gives
you a compliment they don't give it's
not about you
like it's i don't give you a comment for
you i give it to me like it doesn't
matter what you think of yourself
right i think of you you look you look
you listen to the sentence
i think you're beautiful
it's in your head it's me it's in my
head it's me
okay it's just like zombies you know
what i mean they're guns and they're
bombs
zombie yeah man in your head after
after that it's it's it's whatever you
think of that it doesn't matter it
really doesn't matter
and so that's why people they're like
they want you to feel a certain way
because the common one was not about
you or they want to make you feel good
compliment is not about you it's about
me what i think
i don't want to say yeah i look good and
stuff like that i'm not i'm just hey
i'm just me oh you look good i
it's your opinion and it can be i know
it could be really it could be a really
appointment for the person that giving
you again it's giving you the compliment
but that's how i feel i'm sorry i'm like
well thank you
if you see a compliment try to make it
short okay
make it short don't dwell on it and
you're really beautiful
no no really you're really beautiful i
don't really i really wanna
all right hey we got it yeah
move on probably people in the comments
be like why won't you you i'm not
looking for compliments i really don't
care
i have women who drop my dms every day
and they're like oh you're beautiful i'm
just like
okay it really does nothing for me
absolutely nothing so yeah
maybe you guys can relate to this
experience
like we maybe you can relate
here's why i'm saying this here's what
i'm saying this because i'll tell you
this over the last three four years
regardless of whatever women have been
saying to me
as a result of you know my change in
looks or whatever
my self-esteem has not been affected
whatsoever
when i was ugly and get rejected all the
time and when i'm doing pretty good
ladies and
still getting rejected part of the time
doesn't change my self-esteem
so for anyone out there who feels
supremely ugly
right and who struggles all i want to
say to you is
i've been dusty i maybe i'll maybe i'll
put up a picture too
been dusty it's not the end of the world
i may not have been as ugly as you
specifically maybe there's some people
who have been uglier than i have
but i think it's not a difference of
category just a difference of degree
we don't have an experience that is
completely night and day and some of you
were like
i don't believe you because you're
looking at me now but trust me
anybody went to school with me knows how
dusty i was anyone went to high school
worked with me in the military knows how
dusty i was so compliments
that i didn't really work for
oh you got beautiful eyes
i'll thank my mom and my dad i guess i
got like it's
but if you're telling me i like what you
guys do yeah i like yourself i'm like oh
thank you very much for the support
thank you for
liking it or or or not always like
agreeing but you know understanding
where we come from and
thank you for that that's appreciation
thanks for the appreciation yeah and
giving me compliment on something i
worked for yeah
that's that's the most acceptable
compliment that i've received
but like on looks and on on on on
looks and what i wear i'm like well what
you wear still your
fashion you know it feels kind of good
when you're wearing a nice outfit people
like damn that's
fly and and that's probably the only
time
where i'm gonna be like damn man that
jacket looks
nice i know yeah it looks nice
but it's not me here's a weird thing
that's probably the only time but also
when i give compliments i don't operate
that way
i've gone up to girls in clubs and be
like damn that jacket is fire
don't want anything else just want to
let you know when i walk away yeah
because sometimes i just want to show
you i ain't mad and that's that and i
don't care if you're like
or whatever i just want to tell you that
jack is nice and it doesn't matter how
the person reacts after that did you
walk it off no
no i was just thinking it and i wanted
to get out of my head so there you go
like damn girl your ass is fat feels
good
no all right listen that's it for
today's video if you got a fat ass leave
a comment
[Music]
i knew what was when i saw someone i was
showing off
yeah and boasting when i saw that
i didn't like that attitude but yeah i
think i'm the best no matter what
and people used to yeah and people used
to
use that word ah show off it was
something that people would just use
whenever you were doing something nice
yeah you were obviously show off
you can't own the [ __ ] sure no i did
that i ran
fast show off no which i won
yeah it's i it's not not sure i'm not
rubbing in your face i'm not like a
sword winner
i'm just saying yes i'm not abba i'm not
abba when you play his domino you know
what i mean
this guy this guy is this guy who's when
he wins
the [ __ ] out of my fight your mama's sad
right now because you came out of [ __ ]
and all that [ __ ] was for nothing
that happened i've done some of the
worse
but it's true it's not a good look
people like you're arrogant ava and i'm
like i'm just leaning into this because
it's fun for competition
it's not the same it's not because i
don't think you can be super arrogant if
you're
a really good loser you dig what i'm
saying like if i take an
l i'm like you won and i don't harp on
it i don't cry about it i'm like
whatever
and whatever punishment you want to give
me i'm taking it i i gotta admit yeah
i got it yeah if i lose take it and
people are gonna
roast you are you gonna be like okay
okay but you have to understand that if
you roast me while i lose
when i come back yeah it's a show yeah
here's the thing
okay the sword winner thing is just a
matter of making the stakes higher it's
more
fun yes domino's is fun but without
gambling how do you make it more fun and
you add a little pride and ego in there
that's it yeah if i win this game you're
taking shirt off yeah that's right
bam man okay yo give me your shirt yeah
right now you naked
man walk in the street with the homies i
was playing with the homies and then the
white girl sat with us for the first
time and
say why are you guys so mean all the
guys are just like get the [ __ ] out of
here yeah you get to
take all your [ __ ] and get the [ __ ] out
of here
you know when i say that now that that's
hey yeah no
think of it your purse your lands your
glasses your glass
take all of it everything everything get
the it's fun to just raise the stakes
because then it makes it matter more
you know but it's still yeah it's all
that is but yes you were saying
basically you don't want to be seen as
arrogant
yeah and people overuse that so i'm not
i'm not i'm not i want to see